all healthy Ukrainian men between 18 and
60 years old are expected to go to war
unless their job is considered an
essential service but Alex who does not
want to be identified says his friends
have paid up to ten thousand dollars to
avoid conscription he says he didn't pay
a bribe but doesn't want to fight
why because after the age of 45 a man in
this country will become cat and fodder
I have no skills no military knowledge a
lot of comrades were killed because they
only trained for a month and had no
chance a friend who was an excellent
manager was since the front line We
buried him a week ago military
recruiters are not only corrupt he says
they also violate people's rights in
response president valori mirzelanski
has taken a drastic decision and fired
all regional enlistment officers
the system should be run by people who
know exactly what war is and why
cynicism and bribery at a time of war is
high treason instead soldiers who've
been through the front line or who can't
be in the trenches because they've lost
their health can be entrusted with this
recruitment system
he says those who want to keep their
rank should enlist to prove themselves
while soldiers are fighting on the front
line nearby Ukraine is also battling an
internal enemy corruption the country
constantly needs new recruits but with
so many casualties in the
counter-offensive those who don't want
to fight have found a way out
in one case the head of a recruitment
agency forced soldiers to build his
holiday house
in other cases this investigator tells
us men bought fake Health certificates
they applied through intermediaries for
example the drive of the military
commission who then works with doctors
at the military medical commission so
they will issue documents proving the
men are unfit for service
so far 112 cases have been opened he
expects many more Alex blames the
government for his lack of motivation
our state is like a bad mother it
doesn't allow itself to be loved I can
give thousands of examples from my life
when our state has let me down I've
always said that I am a Patriots and
won't leave but I understand those who
do
foreign
with constant funerals and with no end
in sight to the war many men know it's
only a matter of time until it's their
turn
stop fasten Al Jazeera levieve